are you all right i'm all right all  right i'm all right are you all right  i'm happy as you can be in these crazy  times  if season two are heart to heart me and  my celebrity friends are back for more  get ready because it's about to get real  an asian person can affect western  culture i tweeted hey marvel how about  an asian-american superhero are you in  awe of what you've been able to  accomplish i have total belief in myself  it's like a peacock like spreading his  wings a lot of years of oh  i thought the pearly gates of hollywood  were gonna open i don't think people  understand that you asked for the cheese  plate i love food you gotta have crazy  gas  so playing joey ramone from this like  music thing it's like the biggest role  of my life vulture's like i want to be  sedated during his performance  it's something to see as a young guy  trying to achieve the success that you  have already achieved wake up yo i'm  gonna edit this out all right that's  enough  [Music]  you